- Welcome everyone to
the Jackson Institute.
I'm Ted Wittenstein, Deputy
Director for Leadership Programs
and we really have an extraordinary guest,
personal hero of mine,
someone who has traveled
from very far away
to be with us today at Yale, from Manila,
Ann Maria Ressa, who I will
introduce in just a moment,
along with Ambassador Harry Thomas,
one of our Senior Fellows
here at the Jackson Institute,
and someone who was instrumental
in bringing this extraordinary
advocate for human rights
to the Yale campus,
and we welcome her as a
Jackson Visiting Fellow
for the talk today on
"Journalism and Human Rights:
Fighting Back Against Disinformation."
I think many of you are familiar
with the Jackson Visiting Fellows Program.
These are distinguished
practitioners and global affairs,
who are invited to spend
an immersive multi-day
program on the Yale campus.
Many of you have seen and interacted
with some of the visiting
Fellows in this past semester,
including former NATO Commander,
Admiral Jim Stavridis,
former Commander of US Central Command,
General David Petraeus.
Maria Ressa is not a
soldier, but make no mistake,
she is a warrior, fearless,
tireless defender of democracy,
a champion of transparency,
government accountability,
freedom of speech and the press,
both in the Philippines
and around the world,
and often in the face
of great personal risk.
She has been a journalist in
Asia for more than 30 years.
In 2012, she co-founded rappler.com,
which is now one of the
leading news organizations
in the Philippines.
And prior to that,
served as CNN's Bureau
Chief in Manila and Jakarta.
But that's does not do justice
to what the work that she is
doing in the Philippines today
and the way that that
resonates around the world.
When I was sitting in
coffee with Maria yesterday,
she remarked how nice it was to be sitting
and looking out a window
and not fearing sniper fire.
So the work that she is doing is very real
and very risky in defense of
world values and human rights.
She travels with great
security in the Philippines,
she has to train her
staff on how to respond
in the event of surprise
government arrest.
As many of you know,
her reporting on
authoritarian administration
of President Rodrigo Duterte,
has resulted in repeated
intimidation tactics
and a number of manufactured
attempts to detain her.
But she has fought back
against this disinformation
and abuse of power with
great gusto and enthusiasm
in a way that has inspired so many others.
She has said we are journalists
and we will not be intimidated.
We will shine the light,
we will hold the line.
And it is this courageous and
deeply inspirational vision
that has resonated worldwide
that has earned her recognition
as Time magazine Person
of the Year in 2018,
along with numerous other accolades.
And we're delighted
to have Ambassador Harry Thomas
moderate this conversation.
Ambassador Thomas served as
Ambassador to the Philippines
from 2010 to 2013.
He witnessed very racist
efforts firsthand,
he also served as Ambassador
to Bangladesh and Zimbabwe,
along with numerous other senior positions
in the US foreign service.
We're delighted to have Ambassador Thomas
as a Senior Fellow at the
Jackson Institute at Yale.
So Maria Ressa has a brief presentation
highlighting some of the
key work that she's done
in countering authoritarianism
and disinformation.
After which she'll join the
stage with Ambassador Thomas
for a conversation between the two of you
and an interactive Q&A with the audience.
So please join me in thanking Maria Ressa,
welcome her from the
Philippines to New Haven,
to the Jackson Institute and
to Yale, thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
(Maria speaking off the mic)
- Yay, I will run for
about 15 to 18 minutes
and then kinda take you through.
Here are the three points.
The three points I hope
to make in this one
and it's so good to see
so many familiar faces in the audience.
What's the problem?
What's the problem and why should you care
about the Philippines?
Why is our dystopian present
your dystopian future?
And what are the potential solutions?
The problem is very simple.
It is the impact of
technology as an accelerant,
that has helped elect authoritarian
populist-style leaders
that have used the technology
to actually make lies
laced with anger and hate
spread faster than facts.
Without facts, you can't have truth.
Without truth, you can't have trust.
Without any of these, democracy
as we know it is dead.
2020 is a critical year I think.
I hope you guys do really well here
because what happens here
we'll have a global impact.
Why the Philippines?
Because this is the fourth year in a row
that the Philippines is
the social media capital.
100% of Filipinos are on the
internet, 100% are on Facebook.
Facebook is our internet.
I interviewed Cambridge Analytica
whistleblower, Chris Wiley
and I asked him, "What role
did the Philippines play?"
He called it the Petri dish.
He said in countries like ours,
because of the young population.
100 million people, median
age is 23 years old.
Because of that, they tested these tactics
of mass manipulation in our countries
and if it worked on us,
they brought it to you.
They brought it to the
United States to Europe.
So Petri dish is his word,
and he said that if it
worked in the countries
like the Philippines and Nigeria,
that they would then
port the tactics over.
The third part is, I'm not
gonna leave you depressed.
And all So you need to
be extremely empowered,
because you're also a frontline, right?
Some of my problems in our country,
my personal problems,
the attacks against me,
come and happen on American
social media platforms.
Part of what's changed the
entire information ecosystem
is because American social media platforms
who allegedly have the
same values of democracy
that we all have,
is they moved fast and
they broke democracy.
So I hope I'm wrong.
So what is it?
The perfect example is,
in 2018, the Philippine
government filed 11 cases
and investigations against me.
I think that was why,
when I was one of four
covers that they had in 2018,
when I saw this, I
thought it was fake news
and forwarded it to our
social media platform,
to our team because I was like,
"Oh, they didn't tell me."
And then as soon as I
got a call telling me,
it was CNN asking for a
response, my stomach sank
because I thought that meant that,
"Oh my gosh will be attacked again."
But you can't get attacked
more than we have.
Although of course, the
number of cases can go up.
In 2018, because of the cases
that were filed against us,
our revenue dropped almost 50%.
The end goal is to really bankrupt us,
it's a war of attrition.
In 2019. my Valentine's Day
gift from the Government
is to be arrested and
then to be held overnight,
and then within five weeks
to be arrested again.
In order to be here today.
I've posted bail five,
sorry, eight times.
I've posted bail eight times
and I have paid more in bail
and bonds than Imelda Marcos,
who's been convicted in
four different countries.
My lawyer says that one of my
cases, the cyber libel case,
it's a case where we
published a story in 2012,
four months before the law
we allegedly violated was enacted.
This case now began in August 2019
and we'll have a verdict on
April third, please keep track.
I could go to jail for
12 years on that one.
The guardians of truth,
the guardians of truth.
And on the four covers, I was
the only one at that point
who was both alive and free.
This is what it takes to
be a journalist today,
that's crazy, right?
Here's the problem.
It's nice to meet Tim Snyder
in the hallway here yesterday
because I use this slide
almost in every time I speak.
I talked about the problem like this,
if you can make people
believe lies are the facts,
then you can control them.
Tim says it's so much better
and I recommend his book,
"On Tyranny", to everyone,
because it gave me the political,
if we can contain the pollution
in our information ecosystem,
maybe we're only looking
at one or two years
of this dysfunctional democracy.
But if we don't, then
we're looking at decades.
And Tim actually lays out
why and how in "On Tyranny".
He said, if you wanna rip
the heart out of a democracy,
you go after facts.
That's what modern authoritarians do.
Step one, you lie all the time.
Step two, you say it's your opponents
and the journalists who lie.
Step three, everyone
looks around and says,
"What's the truth?"
There is no truth, right?
Because if there is no truth,
resistance is impossible
and the game is over.
What does civic engagement look like
in the age of information warfare?
This time proves power and
information, information is power
and now more than anything,
the Muller Report lays out
Russian disinformation.
I wonder why we keep letting impunity
reign in our information ecosystem?
Here's what we went
through in the Philippines.
In 2017, we started to do a report
along with 12 other research
groups, with a Think Tank.
We came out with the phrase
"Patriotic trolling",
state-sponsored online hate
and harassment campaigns
to silence and intimidate.
They attack you, pound you to silence,
so they use freedom of speech
and expression to stifle a narrative.
If you're pounded to silence,
that's the first step.
The second step is they come
and actually incite hate
and violence against you,
those are the two tactics.
They flood the market with lies.
Instead of actually trying to censor,
you flood the market with lies.
Women are attacked in the
Philippines at least 10 times more
and these were the three steps
because a senator of ours, Lila de Lima,
she's a first-term senator,
but a former Justice Secretary.
She's the former Head of the
Commission on Human Rights.
She's been in prison for three years now
without any real trial,
and she went through these steps as well.
The first is an attack on
credibility that I mentioned.
It's her and me and our Vice President,
who's the head of the opposition.
We were the three cases that came through.
Attack the credibility,
you alleged corruption,
you say it, repeat it exponentially.
A lie told a million times becomes a fact.
You sexual violence, number two.
There was video of her
supposedly, in a sexual act.
It was doctored,
but a Congressman actually
threatened to play it
at the House of Representatives.
The minute you're degraded
as a sexual object,
it's very hard to retain your credibility.
I think I've been called
every animal you can think of,
you develop a thick skin but
I'll show you some of it.
Then the last part is,
before she was arrested,
a few weeks before, they
trended #ArrestLeiladeLima.
In my case,
they tried to trend
#ArrestMariaRessa in May of 2017.
It didn't trend, which is
probably why it took two years
before they arrested me.
This is #MariaRessa
arrest, it was in May 2017.
We came out with the story
of the conversation
between Trump and Duterte,
and we weren't the only ones,
the Washington had posted it as well.
But this is a content creator,
a blogger who now works
for the government.
But at that point, he was one
of the pro-Duterte bloggers.
He writes this, #ArrestMariaRessa,
Rappler just made the Philippines
a legitimate target of North
Korean nuclear missiles.
It's ridiculous right?
And yet, people think it's real.
It's spread to here,
Twitter, campaign accounts.
This is a normal process,
they take social media campaign accounts,
and then pivot and weaponize
it after taking power.
That's what happened in the Philippines.
(mumbles) call her to the
Senate, #ArrestMariaRessa.
Then it jumps to a real person.
I can smell an arrest and
possible closure of rappler.com.
This is made two years
before the government
tried to close us down.
So you can kind of see this astroturfing.
You see the idea first on
social media bottom up, right?
And then we go to the sexualized attacks.
"Maybe Maria Ressa's dream
"is to become the ultimate porn
star in a gang bang scene."
It's not but you know.
This was on our Rappler Facebook page
with millions of followers.
And then this, "Me to the RP Government:
"make sure Maria Ressa gets
publicly raped to death
"when martial law expands to Luzon.
"it would bring joy in my heart."
These are the nicer ones that I got guys.
His school contacted me after I posted,
he was a senior in college
and his school asked if
I wanted to meet him.
I worry, the scorched earth policy.
What does it do to our values?
What does it do to our
young men and our women?
So here's the timeline.
What we did is we began to gather data,
we pulled the data all publicly available
and we took a look at what
was on Rappler's pages
and the way the pages of
newsgroups were being used.
And we pulled out, bayaran
means corrupt (mumbles).
And you can see just like
they did in the United States,
what they do is they look for
a fracture line of society,
normally identity, and then they pound it
until it splits wide open.
Here, it's corruption.
There's a grain of truth
because endemic corruption,
that's norm in the Philippines.
And yes, some journalists are corrupt,
but you can see here from
Jan 2015 to January 2016,
which is when the campaign's began here,
how they began hitting
it far more repetitively.
And then here, may 2016,
that's when President Duterte took office
and July, when the drug war began.
Not coincidentally, the attacks
began with the drug war.
We had one reporter in July of 2016,
who was going out every night
and every night she would come home
with videos of at least eight dead bodies.
Only later would we find
that the average per night was about 32.
That's insane, right?
So what we did is we
put a database together
for our social media team,
Rappler lives on social media.
We drank the Kool Aid.
We really did build communities
of action with social media
and helped Facebook, Twitter
grow in the Philippines.
In this one, did I mention
we're Facebook partners?
We're frenemies, Facebook and me.
We're one of two Filipino
fact-checking partners.
But with that meant we also
had API access here, right?
So in October of 2016, this one here,
these are the URLs that spread the lies.
These are the Facebook pages
and profiles that spread these URLs.
And then if it reposts more
than 10 times, it turns red.
In October 2016, we released
our propaganda war series.
That's the first time
that we looked at how Facebook
algorithms impact democracy,
we took 26 fake accounts
and manually counted
how many other accounts
they could influence.
26 could influence up
to three million others,
that's only 26.
Look at what happened in October of 2016.
This is when the attacks
began against Rappler online
and then I wanna show you
one account that attacked,
every single news group pounded us.
And you can see that
this is a full-time job.
It's a cut and paste,
the same message in page
after page after page
they're posting them in the
campaign pages of Duterte.
You can see here sometimes
the reposting's 55, 80,
and the groups that they
posted in are the Duterte
and the Marcos campaign pages.
This is a full-time job.
So these are the kinds of ways
that you could get manipulated.
In the Philippines is not as much bots
as it is fake accounts.
And then now three years
later, real people.
Think about disinformation like this.
Here's the system and a
great quote by Yuri Andropov,
who's the former head of the KGB
and former head of the Soviet Union.
He said this informatsia
is like taking drugs,
the irony of drugs.
You take it once or twice, you're okay.
You can you can try
cocaine and you'll be okay.
But if you take it all the
time, you're forever changed.
You become a drug addict,
you think differently,
you act differently.
Now imagine that lies,
the information warfare
that we're living through is
coming in, it's like a virus.
And we've now caught it,
so we have to stop the lies
and we have to rehabilitate,
we have to cure us.
We have to rehabilitate us
in order to have democracy
the way it used to be.
Our public sphere has been thrown apart.
I'm gonna show you what an
attack networks looks like,
against the Vice President
of the Philippines.
She's a woman, she's the
head of the opposition.
Doesn't look like anything like this
but when you put it in a network map,
that network is the same
network that attacks me,
that attacks newsgroups,
that attacks any institution
that questions the government.
And it is so systematic
that it is broken down by demographics.
This account creates pseudo
intellectual accounts.
This account,
this is the one that said
hashtag #ArrestMariaRessa,
creates content for the middle class
and this is the anchor
account for the mass base.
She's a singer, dancer,
kind of like a more salacious Spice Girl.
And the attack against Robredo
began here and was amplified.
This is the same network
that attacks newsgroups.
From there, it jumps to
traditional media, Manila times.
While it sounds authoritative,
the Chairman Emeritus is the Head
of International Public
Relations for President Duterte,
and then from there it
jumps to state media.
And around that time, they
announced that they were working
with China and Russia as well.
And then you close that entire loop,
look at our information ecosystem.
You close that loop by
naming our singer, dancer
as Head of Social Media for
the Philippine Government.
So she did that for eight months
and now has a different job in Government.
Yes, I know, welcome to my world.
Historical revisionism.
It's not done by say, starting
here and then jumping there,
you do it little, step by step by step.
And this is, how do you turn Marcos
from someone kicked out
of the country to a hero?
And they did it by cut and
paste comments in Facebook pages
and the comments look really normal.
It's just meant to shift the
way you think a little bit.
"Dark part?
"My parents even say you
can watch TV and news
"and roam around the streets.
"Here, I believe the dark narration
"and full twisting of this part of history
"during my elementary high school days.
"It wasn't all dark.
"The historians and maybe
media made it all dark."
Makes you doubt it.
This happens a lot.
I will tweet you the Marcos
revisionism and it worked.
The Marcoses are back, 34
years after people power.
This is Natural Language Processing
and I just wanna show you
how the threat of an arrest
has played between American news groups
and Filipino news groups.
So this was the first time
an arrest warrant was issued,
the Department of Justice
issued a press release.
And something like 34% of the stories
came from the Philippines and
27% from the United States.
But what's more interesting
is if you do Natural Language Processing
and look at the themes,
and when you look at the themes,
you see the impact of fear.
You see the impact of our own,
is not censorship, it's just being smart.
The stories done in the Philippines
were basically the press release
of the Department of Justice.
Only Rappler asked me for an interview.
And the story's done
outside the Philippines,
here in the United States,
they talked about a
Duterte rights crackdown.
So those are the insidious effects
of fear and violence on a country.
This is what our information ecosystem
looks like on social media.
The size is based on
eigenvector centrality,
the larger the circle, the
more powerful the account.
But this is very similar
to what's happening in the United States.
The Democratic Party, well,
this is our Liberal Party.
But the anti-Duterte forces are small
and they're clustering together,
but they're completely
surrounded by the pro-Duterte,
pro-Marcos communities who
are far more coordinated
in controlling the narrative on Facebook.
The only time we won, we as
in like, who would we call?
People looking for facts, I guess,
the narrative of my
own arrest for example.
We won twice, only twice in three years.
The first time was when I got arrested,
when I got actually arrested,
the second time was when Bono,
U2 came to the Philippines for
the first time in 40 years,
and he used ultraviolet
to honor the women.
So that was really interesting.
Here's what it looked like.
In February last year when I got arrested,
and this is the first time
you can see the information ecosystem
actually kind of split in two,
but the methodology is interesting
because normal people, people who duck,
who put their heads like
ostriches in the sand
because it's too complex,
it's too confusing,
too much violence, so
they'd rather look away.
But when I got arrested, they
actually started tweeting
or posting the news groups.
But if you look at the
pro-Duterte, pro-Marcos clusters,
they actively avoid
tweeting traditional media.
In fact, they post stories.
They're kind of trying to create
their own version of Alex Jones.
Oh, yeah, that was the
salacious singer, dancer.
She's just not as good as Alex Jones.
He was ultimately taken down, right?
Look at here,
they're looking for alternative
media sources here, right?
That's what we're seeing,
and it split pretty evenly.
One of my team members said,
"Maria, you should have stayed
in jail a night longer."
I'm like, "Thanks, guys."
I wish, not it's not a good thing.
How does it connect?
Every country is connected
to a global nervous system
of disinformation networks.
In 2018, December 2018, the US
Senate Intelligence Committee
released a ton of data, it's here,
and what we saw here is
how this American academic
who's closely affiliated
with RT and Sputnik,
that's why they're there,
also writes for an
alt-right Canadian website
called globalresearch.ca.
But he also writes for this website
that has an IP in Russia,
and he is the most quoted
expert of this account.
It's called dailycentury.net,
this is Rappler being attacked.
But this account has since
been taken down by Facebook.
It was working directly with this.
The web of interconnections
between the alt-right in the US,
the alt-right in Canada and
weirdly, the Philippines.
We don't have an alt-right, right?
So these are the disinformation networks
that are starting to work together.
I'll leave you with what
our world looks like,
oh, I wanna show you the
impact on Rappler, I forgot.
Rappler is a startup, right?
Well, not so startup anymore, in 2012.
So this is (mumbles), but I
just wanna show you in 2012,
this is how we began.
The red is the spend,
we always spent more,
the blue is the revenue, right?
I always meant to break even
here, in 2016, our year five,
normal newsgroups break
even at least 10 years,
five years later from that.
So a tech-enabled newsroom
breakseven faster.
So we did, April 2019 was our first month
of positive net income.
President Duterte was elected in May.
Even though we had positive net income
through the rest of the year,
the attacks drove our revenue down.
So the other thing that we learned
is advertisers will not be at
the frontline of defending.
But even when our revenues
went down, we continue to build
and then we slashed the
next year and guess what?
In 2019, the year I have eight charges,
the year I got arrested,
we actually made money.
Crisis is opportunity, right?
And the flip side is that we
diversified our revenue stream
because we were forced to.
Necessity is the mother of invention.
And the things that were
investigative-journalism-driven,
the things that we did as
investigative journalist
to figure out the disinformation networks
are the very things
that allowed us to grow
this revenue stream.
I'll leave you with these.
This is what our world is today.
Tim Snyder said it here, rip
the heart out of a democracy.
But this is the situation
in the Philippines.
"Combined with online and offline violence
"to create a climate of fear."
It is a climate of fear.
We're being live-streamed,
I will tell you this.
"Anyone who questions a brutal drug war,
"supports those who fight for truth.
"Attack them with the full force
"of the Philippine Government.
Lila de Lima has been
in jail for three years
without a proper trial.
I don't know what I am.
Someone actually told me,
I don't have to be in prison right now.
Because in a way, I already am in prison.
It depends, it's like a game of chicken.
How far do you go?
You don't know.
And it took a while to actually tell me
all of the charges I face,
if I lose all of them,
the maximum sentence
is 83 years in prison.
You make them cautionary
tales for demanding the truth.
So what do we do, what do we do?
We start with the area of influence,
you demand accountability from power.
We continue to do that.
if each of us does that we put
our patch of ground together,
stand up against bullies, report the lies,
demand accountability
from your American social media platforms.
Those are my two things that
I demand, an end to impunity,
our government on the
drug war and Facebook.
"Tell your family and
friends, courage spreads.
"We begin by taking care
of what's in front of us."
I'm gonna leave you, it isn't
just Rappler who's doing this.
It is every Filipino journalist.
Journalists are under attack globally.
And I'll leave you with
a minute and a half video
that shows you some of the
things we have to deal with.
- [Interviewer] You ever been
harassed because of your work?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been threatened online?
(speaks in foreign language)
Have you been called biased?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been called stupid?
- Yes, many times by idiots.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been called disrespectful?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been accused of corruption?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you been called ugly
as a response to any story?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been called fake news?
- Oh, yeah, they always say I'm fake news.
Anything that's critical is fake, right?
- [Interviewer] Have you been accused
of being an imperialist spy?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you been accused
of being a communist operative?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you been accused
of working for the CIA?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been sexually harassed
as a journalist?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Has your
family been threatened,
harassed or alluded to?
- Yes, it has specifically
my daughter when she died.
There were a lot of people
who made fun of that.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been threatened with rape?
- Yes.
- No, not me but my family.
- [Interviewer] Have you been
threatened with violence?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been threatened with death?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you been told
how you're going to be killed?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Has the
violence been described to you?
- Yeah, blow my head off or bury me alive.
- [Interviewer] What will
stop you from reporting?
- Nothing.
- Death.
- Dude, you have to kill me.
- We hold the line.
(audience clapping)
- Good evening.
(speaking in foreign language)
Welcome everyone, I think
we were all impressed.
I'm going to start off as a moderator
with just a couple of questions,
and then we really would
like to hear from the guests,
especially the students,
as they asked my good friend
Maria Ressa questions.
And I learned a lot from Maria
during my time in the Philippines.
She wrote a book.
Facebook have been
long, 10 days, 10 years,
about terrorism and kidnapping,
ABS CBN (mumbles) she
worked with reporters
and southern Philippines and
how they work to return them.
I was so impressed by the book
that I invited her to my residence
to talk to my team about
what you needed to learn.
Like many of our fellow,
my fellow diplomats,
Ted and and (mumbles),
we thought we knew a lot.
Well, I realized what I did,
I thought I knew a lot
about the Philippines
until I married a Filipina and
realized I did not know much.
And that's the way it
is in many countries.
You have to have to learn
and you have to be brave.
So my first question Maria, is why stay?
- Oh wow, the basic questions
are the hardest, right?
I think I have to stay, right?
I mean, it kind of is horrible,
that we come of age at different times.
And I'm now a senior
journalist in the Philippines
and the baton was passed to me
at a time that's really
horrific for journalists.
But I think that I wouldn't be me
if I didn't find it head on.
Like, it's easy to say you
have standards and ethics,
it's easy to say you believe
in the mission of journalism,
but if you duck when it
matters, then you don't.
That kind of played around with my head,
'cause I did think about it.
I'm both an American
and a Filipino citizen.
My family is so adamant,
so I asked my mom to leave the Philippines
and come back to the States.
But the reality is that I
don't think I have a choice.
You have to hold the line
because when you give it up,
then you voluntarily give up your rights.
Guys, don't voluntarily
give up your rights.
- Thank you very much for that.
Philippines for all its wandering beauty
has the last decade,
been the most dangerous
country for journalists,
and yet you are encouraging
young people to enter journals.
How and why do you do this?
- I hate when he's
asking questions, right?
(audience clapping)
I used to do this and it
was more fun asking him,
because, I think you saw, right?
Our information ecosystem,
creative destruction,
it's already been destroyed.
And so what we're doing in Rappler
is trying to deal with that destruction,
journalists have lost
our gate keeping powers,
we're no longer gatekeepers,
it went to tech.
And tech has decided
that politicians can lie.
That's actually what Mark
Zuckerberg said, right?
And so this is the time
when after the old world
we know has been destroyed,
you come in and you create
what the new world is gonna be.
That's incredible, right?
And that's part of the reason
I stay and I work every day.
I used to think when I was in CNN,
I work really hard at 24 hour news.
Forget that, Rappler is like
every hour of every day,
it's 150% of what you want.
But part of it is because, and
I'll toss this back to you,
this is the time that matters.
Everything that we grew up with,
everything that we knew is under attack.
Our democracy is under attack.
When journalists are under attack,
democracy is under attack.
And so I feel like what we do matters.
And for the young journalists
here in this room,
when you jump in now, you're
not gonna do what I did
when I started as a reporter,
which is to follow what
someone else has done.
You'll actually be creating new things.
And the better you
understand data, technology,
and society, behavioral science,
the better your journalism will be.
- Thank you very much.
Now we'll ask everyone who
is going to make a question,
please identify yourself and
keep your question brief.
And it will go around,
but I would I would first
like to give the opportunity
to two, one new friend, one old friend.
Vicki Acevedo is here tonight,
she was in the second
class of Women at Yale,
went on to Harvard Law School
and has had a distinguished
career and we welcome her.
I'd like to know, Vicki if
you have a question (mumbles).
- [Vicki] Let me just first of all,
say thank you very much
for that presentation.
I mean, the big data
issue is so important.
I just been wondering about
the revelation of truth.
I watch CNN or CNBC or PBS,
and they have consistently
pointed out the lies,
all the time, but it doesn't
seem to make any difference.
So I wonder if you could address that.
You partially did
in talking about people
who put their heads down,
but why is it that
revealing the lying behavior
doesn't change the citizens behavior?
- So I think two reasons.
The first is, Daniel Kahneman's book,
"Thinking Fast, Thinking Slow", right?
Our old world was thinking slow.
Journalists rational thinking
stood a chance in that world,
because we valued it.
Those were the rules in
the systems we created.
The new world rule and enabled by tech,
is actually driven by
thinking fast, right?
It's a Thinking Fast world,
you can't call them anything
but behavioral modification systems.
Social media platforms are
behavioral modification systems
and we are Pavlov's dogs walking into it.
The wrong behavior is rewarded, right?
So Mark will say that it
is about freedom of speech.
It isn't about freedom of speech,
because you can say anything
you want but not everything,
and especially when it's violence.
Not everything should
have wide distribution.
And in the social media platforms,
what actually gets
distributed faster and further
are incendiary comments, lies
laced with anger and hate.
You know it, it's part of who we are.
It's almost like the devil and
the angel on our shoulders,
except the devil keeps winning
because the the platform itself
takes our reactions and keeps us engaged,
engaged, I'm beginning to hate that word,
by playing to the worst of human nature,
by playing to the devil in us.
So part of Duterte's
power comes from the fact
that not only does he
say those rich peoples,
'cause one of the narratives they divided,
the first division was
between the rich and the poor,
which is really huge in the Philippines,
but what he did is he
promised the poor revenge,
a different thing.
The thinking fast part is the part.
And that's part of the reason I think
that this is built by design.
We are mildly addicted with
elevated levels of dopamine,
you have elevated levels of oxytocin
so that you stay and you share.
So all of this must change,
but I think part of it
is because the tech guys had full rein.
For law if there is no rule of law,
there is no democracy also
and that's part of the problem
because in the virtual world,
there is no rule of law.
And online violence leads
to real world violence.
We know that also, those are clear.
So that's part of the reason
I think the world is upside
down does that makes sense?
We gotta fix the tech.
- Thank you, and now, Sheila Marcelo,
COO of Care, Yale parent,
Harvard and (mumbles).
- [Sheila] Maria, thank
you for doing this.
You're such a good friend
and I am such a huge fan
for your heroic efforts
and what you're doing for
people and freedom of speech.
And so when I think about, Ron and I,
were just at the last World
Economic Forum at Davos
and recently also just with some friends.
And we were talking about the debate,
the pressures on Mark and
Sheryl, as they think about it,
and at Davos, we heard a debate
that New York Times hosted
between regulation of big
data and self-regulation,
like how should we
really think about that?
So if you had Mark in front of you,
which I know you've had opportunities
to chat with him directly,
from a self-regulation perspective,
because I keep hearing from friends,
the argument that it's a
lose-lose situation for him.
Because that if he regulated
and became the arbiter of
what was lies or truth,
that's not really the
technology that you he built
nor does he believe that that is his role.
And so what for a business person,
are the personal responsibility
given that you've studied this so well.
Like if you were talking to him today,
what would be your advice to him
around what he could be actively doing
for self-regulation in the technology?
Because, again, I've heard the argument,
because of the conservatives,
he'll say, well, they're gonna attack me
if I shut down all the
lies, they're going up.
Is it really about
Liberals and Conservatives?
So what would you say to Mark?
- So I think even without doing anything,
the platforms are already making choices,
but the way they're making choices
is they are rewarding lies,
they're rewarding the manipulation.
And this is documented
in the Mueller Report.
The networks of disinformation,
Russian disinformation.
Guys, you're manipulated.
I mean, that's already a fact
and the fact that we
don't know it's a fact,
it's really scary because
it will happen again
and it is happening again.
That's first.
The second I think is.
So the excuse that I don't
wanna regulate speech,
you're already doing it
because you took the old rules,
you trash them and you
replace them with rules
that are not friendly to democracy.
Journalists spend all our lives
learning how to make
boring facts interesting.
We learn how to tell stories,
it's really hard to keep your attention.
But now in the age of social media,
someone will just lie and
lace it with anger and hate
and we just don't stand
a chance in distribution.
So that's the second part, what solution?
I think there was this
brief period of time
when they had free reign,
and I think it was when Instant
Articles was brought in.
All the news groups were
brought into Facebook.
Facebook from that time period,
by 2016, became the world's
largest distributor of news.
Not coincidentally, 2016 is
when the dominoes began to fall.
In May, the election of Duterte,
a month later was Brexit,
Trump was November,
then you go all the way
to the Catalonia elections that year.
Because we found bots that were working
in both the US and Catalonia elections
tweeting exclusively
about the Philippines.
So we know this is happening.
I think it takes leadership,
I think it's enlightened self interest.
Because if they don't change course,
an ambassador would know this, right?
Whatever you do, you will be attacked,
but you have to do the right thing.
So the question back to him
is, what are your values?
What are the values that govern this?
It's almost like they created a city
and gave everyone a machine
gun and then said, go at it.
And Mad Max wins, that
isn't the way society works.
And it filters to reality
because online, virtual world is reality.
The millennials here know that, right?
That's the reason why I
think it will take time.
A solution?
I've been thinking about this
and we talked about this
at lunch a little bit
is data portability, a potential
one, short-term solution.
Because I don't wanna break up Facebook,
even though a lot of the
legislations looking at antitrust.
I don't wanna break 'em up
because they did have the advantage,
but how do you help younger groups
like Jimmy Wales's new
social media platform?
What if we give Facebook
incentive to protect the users?
'Cause right now, every
incentive they have
is actually to continue
going down this path
to the destruction of democracy.
They spent more money
protecting our privacy,
they were pummeled by the
market, they lost a lot of money.
So what if a user like me,
if I get attacked a lot,
I can tell take all the data
I created on the platform
and poured it over to Jimmy
Wales' new social media platform
And I can take my family
and friends with me
'cause I'll do that.
They will protect us if they
will lose the network effect.
So I think that's part of
what we have to think about.
But the reason why I don't
think self-regulation works
is 'cause they had the chance
and they didn't take it.
So it goes back to what are the values?
I think tech is not neutral, at any level.
- Thank you, next question
please, young man at the back.
- Thanks a lot, Maria.
Did you--
- Stand up for me please.
- [Kyle] Sure.
Hi, how are you?
My name's Kyle.
- You referred to Facebook
as a distribution platform,
and so I was wondering if these lies
and the deceit and the
manipulation that you referred to.
I was wondering if this has occurred
on previous platforms in media history.
Did this happen when the
television came to be?
Did this happen through radio,
in the printing press and so forth?
And if so, how did we
regulate it in the past?
- So I think we've never been at a stage
where the rate of spread is exponential.
This is truly game-changing, right?
You're talking just Facebook alone,
and I have to say, we're frenemies
'cause we're partners of Facebook.
I don't sound like it, do I?
I know the good it can do
which is part of the
reason I get disappointed
when it doesn't do the good it can do.
So, television, this printing press.
Yes, there's something
different with each one,
but it has never been at the edge
of a human's ability to ingest.
Part of it is, it's like the difference
between an Excel sheet and big data.
The difference in scale
creates a completely
different world, right?
So when you're doing big data,
you can see all these patterns,
you won't be able to see
in a small Excel Sheet.
I think that the the tech platforms
have enabled so many good things
but at the same time,
they've also enabled the rise
of these populist authoritarian leaders
that are using these same platforms
to use information operations
against their own people,
to change democracy and this is a stat.
In 2017, Freedom House came
out with the first study
that said that in at least 28
countries around the world,
cheap armies and social media
were rolling back democracy.
Last year, Oxford University's
Computational Propaganda Research Project
said that number is now
at least 70 countries.
So what do we do?
Well, what has happened in
every industry, tech will say,
"Look, this is a really
difficult industry to regulate."
Is it any more difficult
than the airline industry
or finance or pharmaceuticals?
We have regulated very complex industries
and you never allow a drug
makers to test the drug in public
and say, let the user beware
or let me get them to say,
okay, and then they can get poisoned.
That's kind of what's happening, right?
The onus is on the user
that you're supposed to opt out or opt in.
It's not about opting out or opting in,
it's about knowing that
when I get on a plane,
I don't have to know how the plane works
to know the I'll be safe in the plane.
That's what governments
are supposed to do, right?
I didn't really answer your question
because I think we're at that phase
where we're looking for the answer.
And I'll connect it to one thing
which is similar to the
end of World War Two.
At the end of World War Two,
the atom bomb scared everybody.
Hitler scared everyone
and as a global community,
we came together to create
Bretton Woods, NATO,
the UN Declaration of Human Rights,
that we decided that we
need to protect humanity
from the worst of what human beings do.
We're at the same juncture today.
And information is the problem now, right?
But we don't agree that
an atom bomb went off.
So the entire system has
already gone up and smokes,
but we don't even realize it.
That's scary.
Should there be Christopher Wiley?
The Cambridge analytical
whistleblower said that,
in his book he recommended,
there should be building
codes for tech platforms.
There should be ethical codes.
Tristan Harris, Head of Humane Tech,
he was Google's ethicist at some point.
The other thing Wiley said is,
every individual coder
should be legally liable
for the code that they create.
I'm just saying this is a brave new world.
No altruism, right?
It's a brave new world and
we have to like grapple,
call a spade a spade
and demand protection.
As a journalist, the Philippines,
in the United States,
our Constitution is patterned
after the United States.
I'm protected under the Constitution
of both of our countries and yet,
all of that protection was stripped
the minute I entered the virtual world.
- Thank you, next question please.
Yes, sir.
- [Bob] My name is Bob
and my question is this.
If we're going to change course,
we're going to need new narratives.
My question is, where do these
new narratives come from?
And maybe what might be in the them?
- I wish Harry (mumbles)
would answer that question.
(Maria laughing)
The new directions I think,
the one word that I don't
hear a lot in tech is values
which underpins America.
It underpins every society
that pushes for progress.
So I think the first is,
you can see I'm very
influenced by social media
because I grew Rappler from zero
to being the third-top
online news website,
we're the top digital only website.
And I can see that the
incentives are all skewed
because it happened so fast,
the rush to grow these platforms.
So tech for me is something
we cannot discount.
I also don't think we should kill tech.
Sheila built a business
on using tech, right?
Tech does enable, but when
we see something wrong
for business men in particular,
there has to be some
stop, some accountability.
So what to do?
Obviously, our political systems
have already been affected.
I came with something very simple,
which is in your area of influence,
please demand what you believe,
what values you stand for,
what you believe should happen.
Make facts important because
everyone jumps to thinking fast
instead of thinking slow.
Shares, our generation is
the one that shares lies
seven times more than the millennials,
because we grew in a
world of trust, right?
In a way, these social
media platforms benefited
from the trust that's embedded
in the way we build our
businesses and communities.
And now we're going to have to
rebuild that and rethink it.
I'm sorry, it's a fudgy answer.
Maybe our esteemed Ambassador,
do you have an idea?
Find a new leader.
No, sorry.
(everybody laughing)
Oops.
- I wouldn't go there, I'm retired now,
I can say whatever I would
like but I would say the truth,
justice values still reign
and they are so important
and we cannot abdicate that
under any circumstances
and we cannot become transactional.
(mumbles) you had a question.
Just call me sir.
- [Steven] My name is Steven,
thank you for being here.
I saw the documentary on
cable, very impressive for you.
My problem is this, I'll make this short,
I've been leading nonprofit
for the last close to 10 years
and I worked with
Egyptian students in Cairo
when our spring occurred and
I work with Ukrainian students
and I work with Syrian students.
And the problem is, they end
up all preaching to the choir.
They don't reach out,
Ukraine has done that
more than the other two.
But the Arab Spring failed in Egypt
because they were just
talking to themselves.
And my question to you is,
are you reaching out to people
who are not in your camp?
Because I happen to know
more than a few Filipinos in New York,
and they tell me, they know about Duterte
and they know it is craziness or whatever,
but they say, You know what?
He's done a lot for us.
Yes, he's killed a lot of people,
but a lot of those people are
drug war lords or whatever.
Do I care about Maria Ressa?
Yes, but the bottom line is,
Duterte's done so much for us
that I'll just ignore it.
It doesn't really matter to me.
I just want Duterte to continue,
we have a much more stable society.
That's like it is here
with Trump and his appeal.
So my question to you is,
are you really appealing to
people who are not of your ilk?
And if so, let us know.
Thank you.
- Thanks for your question.
So number one, is that I
never was of an ilk, right?
I mean, I'm a journalist
and I actually really did live with this.
The problem now is, when
my rights were violated,
I had first-hand knowledge
of how the government abused its powers
and I decided then to take a step forward
into something that's
pretty uncharted for me.
I talked about the injustice that I saw.
I was unshackled and I
hold government to account
because my Government
abused its power, right?
I'm not taking a side, I never have.
I'm not a political
animal, I'm a journalist.
The Liberal Party in the Philippines
will say part of the
reason Duterte got elected
is because Rappler covered him
and gave a presidential debate.
We covered all five camps
equally and continue to do that.
Unfortunately, we refuse to
stop doing investigative reports
and you can say, oh,
it feels really great.
It's okay to kill a few people,
which by the way, AstroTurf
messages on social media,
which is meant to change
the way people think.
So that happens but at the same time,
look this year, foreign
direct investment is down 31%.
If you look at the facts, the
facts say a different thing,
but what happens when facts don't matter?
Take a look at the Philippines.
Facts have to match because in the end,
we negotiate everything
in a public sphere.
And I need to listen.
By no means do I think
I have any solution.
I guess that's the best
part of being a reporter.
You want to get the best
knowledge from everyone else
so you can put the best thing together.
Running a company is similar to that.
That's the kind of role I play in Rappler,
I try to get the best ideas
and we pull them together.
That's what democracy should be.
It isn't about one side yelling at another
or saying this is better than yours.
Which by the way,
came from inciting a mob
in the public sphere.
This is information warfare.
So I go back to that, yes, I do.
Number two, we reach out all the time.
Many of the propagandists in
that network that I showed you
were part of our civic engagement team.
And it is so painful
to see some of these
tactics then being used.
Before this time as a
reporter, as a journalist,
I've never used good versus
evil in the way I do now.
I think the advice I gave last
night to some Yale students
is that the values are so important now.
I think while you're still
in school, define that line.
Where on this side, you're good
and on this side, you're evil.
Because the world is complex
and it literally manipulates you.
So be clear who you are, what
are the values you stand for?
And I think that's the best thing.
So my quick response is I
continue trying to reach out,
but when I'm vilified
and portrayed exponentially
as a tax evader,
even though my company
was given the top corporate tax awards
six months before they filed
five tax evasion cases against us.
I get angry so I learned anger management.
- Thank you, next question please.
Yes, right behind.
- [Sarah] Hi, my name is Sarah.
I'm a second year student
at the law school here.
So it appears that your
seemed to be more in favor
of stricter regulation within big tech
and social media platforms.
So what is your opinion
on stricter media laws?
So for example,
for demonstrably false
information i.e fake news,
do you think that should be criminalized?
- One of the things we're fighting against
in the Philippines is that
libel is a criminal offense.
The cyber libel means that
the penalty is double,
normal libel and I face criminal charges.
So we've long been against
criminalizing libel.
So here's another complexity
to add to the layer.
Our old world was complex enough,
when you add the layer of tech.
Look at a country like Singapore.
Singapore is about 5 million people,
Harry can talk more about this,
but Singapore has 10-year plans
and they're actually very efficient.
It's a democracy not in the way we are.
They pass the first fake news law.
Maybe second, Malaysia was
first in Southeast Asia.
And now it's being used against folks
who are perceived to be
critical of government.
There isn't a one size fits all answer,
and there certainly isn't a quid pro quo.
If we regulate tech,
should we regulate media?
If we regulate media,
should we not regulate?
There isn't anything like that,
these are false equivalences.
I think for me, all I'm
trying to do is to go back
to how do we protect the public sphere?
How do we take the new technology,
machine-learning, artificial intelligence.
These platforms know you more intimately
than your most intimate relationships,
because you put that data in there.
It's not content, it's behavior, right?
So I'm trying to understand the world
and trying to stay out of jail (laughing).
- Thank you, next question.
Yes, young man.
Patient.
Walking (speaking off mic).
- [Greg] Hi I'm Greg, I'm a
student here from Indonesia.
And I know that you were in Jakarta
during the democratic transition
between Suharto and the reform period,
and in Manila be fore that.
So having seen and reported
on a lot of authoritarians,
how is it different now
or is it just the same?
- I started my career in 1986,
34 years ago with People Power,
and then I was very privileged with CNN,
they gave me a front-row
seat right when I felt like,
oh my gosh, these changes from
authoritarian one man rulers,
Singapore, Lee Kuan Yew to Goh Chok Tong,
Mahathir stepping down
and now of course he was
back and now he stepped down.
And then Indonesia,
the end of almost 32 years
of Suharto was incredible.
I felt like the pendulum,
like a pendulum was released
and it was swinging back.
And I think the painful
part for me three years ago
was to see that pendulum go back.
And went back because of the
in formation ecosystem, right?
So Indonesia has similar problems.
The top Twitter city in
the world is Jakarta.
And let's look back to the days of Suharto
when the violence and unbond in 1999.
10, 000 people were killed
because one newspaper printed
something that was incendiary.
Grenade was thrown in a
mosque and the killers,
do you remember?
This was before you were
born, how old are you?
(Maria laughing)
- Born '99.
- Yay.
But so I remember then
how difficult that was
and that was only a newspaper.
And then we saw the riots, the
Jakarta riots again recently
and Indonesia actually had
to a hawk, those are sorry,
you know this better
than I do that ethnic,
communal violence, the
time I was in Jakarta,
I went through all 27
at that point provinces,
and I think I covered every single
form of conflict in a town.
From ethnic violence from, the (mumbles),
the beheadings that happen there.
This was in 1997 from
Archer separatism, violence.
It's a tinderbox and I
worry about social media.
Sorry, I ran off into
where I wanted to go.
I worry about the information ecosystem.
I think that when you
manipulate us emotionally,
we have no defenses against it.
And when it is done for power,
we cannot hold our governments to account.
- [Ron] So just a quick follow up.
Your walked down, thank
you again, always an honor.
- You're such a familiar, thank you.
- [Ron] I'm Ron, I'm Sheila's husband.
And your walk down memory lane
made me think of a term,
"puppet government",
which I thought the general
public of most of those nations
that were under puppet governments,
recognized the influence
of money behind the leaders
and again, the general public
so the majority of the people.
And now in this age, my
question really is about,
that term in my opinion,
doesn't seem to be used anymore
because seems this big money
has somehow in new systems,
gotten somehow to a tipping
point our country as an example,
where it's sort of mass
the influence of big money
to command sort of what
we're seeing in policy
and the outcomes.
Could you comment a little
about how to make that big
money more transparent today?
That again, I would say, the
majority of people would say,
that's not a good thing to
have big money influencing us
in this way through
these funded campaigns.
So for example, the Marcoses
are still billionaires.
Some people in this room
might not know that,
but that is still a fact.
- ICIJ, are you guys familiar with ICIJ?
International Center for
Investigative Journalism?
There's huge data that
has been released globally
and journalists in many
different parts of the world
come together to work on this data.
Some of that data exposes
the Marcos wealth.
The Panama Papers if
you're familiar with that,
that came from ICIJ's collaborative work.
What you really made me think of
and I guess I went off on
an aside from your question
was the geopolitical power,
'cause beyond the corporations
is actually the money
that, I see this in the Philippines,
the money that's flowing
in the Philippines
that is helping change geopolitical power.
China, Russia, United States,
the Philippines is pivotal,
always has been, right?
And in October 2016 when President Duterte
went to Beijing on a state visit
and he didn't tell his
Foreign Affairs Secretary,
that he announced that the
Philippines would move away
from the United States,
pivot to China and Russia.
That was the first time I
heard Russia in Beijing.
So that money has come in.
Badly, we know this, and
we're trying to track that.
Morality the rebuilding of
morality in the Philippines
is Chinese right supposedly,
but the rebuilding hasn't happened.
So I'm just saying that the money
is a money flow of governments
for geopolitical power,
and then you're talking
about the kind of money
that families would have.
What we're seeing right
now in the Philippines
is the building of a new kleptocracy.
And you're seeing it in plain sight,
because it's two years
before the end of
President Duterte's term.
He has one six-year term,
and they're now getting
ready for elections next,
campaigns will begin next year.
So what's happening is
the blue chip companies,
the largest conglomerate in the
Philippines, the Ayala Group,
has been forced to
essentially sell it's shares
to businessmen chosen who are
friendly to President Duterte.
The kleptocracy is
happening in plain sight.
Harry you should talk more this.
So yes, the flow of money is important.
Can it be more transparent?
Yes.
Has it ever been transparent
in the Philippines?
Never.
Which is why investigative
journalism is also important.
We're trying to do more
it, it's scary for me
that you have the lobbyist
group, a conglomerate,
the Ayala Group, the First
Pacific Group, Manny Pangilinan.
these are three big conglomerates
who are being forced,
like the Philippine Daily
Inquirer, to sell their shares.
For money to change hands,
because again, a
kleptocracy is being built.
We're not the first country
where there's a kleptocracy,
so all these words oligarchs,
the names change but the
system remains the same.
- Thank you, young lady.
Right here, yes.
- [Marianne] Hello, Marianne,
I'm a senior from the Philippines--
- And her father is one of
the investors of Rappler.
(everybody laughing)
Sorry, I didn't mean.
- [Marianne] I was wondering,
so it seems like the world
that we're living in,
well, the Philippines Marcosian
kind of like media censorship
seems to be rearing its
ugly head once again,
like, you've had all of these lawsuits
and arrest warrants against you.
I think just last week, the
National Police brought up
that Presidential Decree
number 90 under Marcos,
which is about like rumor mongering,
which is defunct but they're
kind of returning to that
and this whole thing with ABS CBN,
one of the major national networks
on the verge of being closed down.
So I was just wondering
how you are navigating
that kind of tricky space.
- It's like a game of chicken.
You just keep going down the right path.
So my lawyers, I asked my lawyers this.
Right before we came in here,
I was on with my lawyers.
So I asked my lawyers
this, what can they do?
They can do anything,
that's really the reality.
I could be charged with child abuse.
And I guess my best defense,
my only defense is to shine the light.
To tell you the story, to
tell you what's happening.
I think the reason why
Rappler is still alive
is because one, we're owned
largely by journalists.
We decided that we would hold the line
and then two, we asked
international news groups
to tell our story.
And it reverberates
because it's happening in many
countries around the world.
So I guess part of it is,
they always say don't
sweat the small stuff.
It's now the small stuff is so big.
It's like, oh, I could go to
jail, I won't think about it.
I'll just focus on where I need to go.
And that works for now.
That's why I'm also hoping
our allies, the tech allies,
now frenemies, remember?
I keep appealing.
So I work very closely
with the tech companies,
because they're really
critical for the first step.
What does civic engagement look like
in the age of social media for your group?
That's a long-winded answer.
I think the short answer is,
we look at people like you.
We are developing the next
generation of journalists.
This time requires far more
courage than at any other time.
And you at Yale are so
privileged and powerful.
And please like the thinking-slow
world, I so long for that,
because we can't move
forward without that.
- [Joe] My name is Joe, Joe (mumbles),
I'm a Filipino-American.
I'm an officer of the Association here
so I'm part of the community.
And I'm also part of the battleground
because as part of the community,
I know what the gentleman
here said a while ago.
There are so many pro-Duterte
Filipino-Americans as well.
And it feels to me like
it was even harder now.
I was also a anti-Marcos activist
in my years in the University
of the Philippines.
It was even easier then than it is now.
I can easily reason
with pro-Marcos supporters
before in the 80s
than to do it with
pro-Duterte supporters now,
and many of them are my
former colleagues in the left.
So we were split.
We are coming to 2022, that's
the presidential elections.
We were clobbered in social media.
So it was very hard to do the
debates or to win in debates.
What is your outlook of 2022
in terms of the battlefield,
that means the information battlefield?
Because we will be in there again,
we will be debating with our friends
who are with the other camp,
and we were clobbered because
they were so organized
and we were coming from different places.
How are we gonna win this,
if you have any ideas,
for people like us who
are in the community?
- I think it's impossible
to win the social media war
unless you have no values.
The only way to win this is
it's a scorched-earth policy.
It's the use of anger and hate to spread
and you demonize someone else.
It's a world that I don't believe in
which is why when Mark Zuckerberg says,
we don't want to be the arbiters
of truth, you already are.
They're prioritizing speech
that incites the hate
and violence more than they
prioritize facts, right?
This is built into the system.
So I think the first thing is,
I called it a behavioral
modification system,
but think about it like this.
In this system that they've created,
they decided that they wanted
to grow it fast, so fast,
there's a cost to growing it fast.
So a tech person made the decision
that they're going to
use friends of friends,
because if it's friends of
friends, just that one decision,
you'll be able to close triangles,
there's a paper by Mark Granovetter
called The Strength of Weak Ties.
So they close these triangles,
but in doing that, they build
polarization into that system.
Because friends of friends,
so think about like this,
if you have rightist tendencies,
like in our world maybe it was like this,
in the Philippines it was like this,
in the US you had Fox and CNN
so you had your own media things.
But in the Philippines we were like this.
So if I had rightist tendencies
and I only talked to my friends
and grew my network of friends,
then I moved further here.
And then if I had leftist tendencies
and I only talked to all my friends
and grew my own network of friends,
I move further here, you
never see the other side.
Eli Pariser wrote a book
about The Filter Bubbles,
this is in the design,
so how do we do that?
It's not about conversation or
even listening to each other
or convincing each other.
In order to convince someone,
you have to listen to each other.
That's not built into the design.
So I've seen good people
use the exact same black
strategy as the Duterte camp.
And you know what, it leaves
a trail and we can see that.
I don't think that's the
right way to go either.
That's part of the reason
I think we need to demand
that the platforms change
the way they create a system,
because they talk about a market of ideas,
a market has rules.
You check out here., you
don't bring a gun in, right?
You have to have rules for
a marketplace of ideas.
Because right now,
you can't insure that election
integrity even exists.
We can't, because the information
ecosystem is so flawed.
- Thank you, so very much.
Salama (background noise
drowns the speaker)
(audience clapping)
(lively upbeat music)